when I started working in the media
industry I started off at CBS Radio
which is very much like traditional news
and I was depressed I was there for
about 6 months before I realized oh my
God the best that I could ever do in an
environment like this is work my way up
to being an anchor and the anchors would
come in like 10 minutes before the
broadcast and just regurgitate what was
written for them and I found that so
boring um there was no mental
stimulation involved I just hate needed
it and one day one of my colleagues
there came up to me and asked you know
are you interested in doing this temp
job for two weeks it's for a new show
called The Young Turks and I was like
The Young Turks what is that and I asked
a bunch of questions about the name and
once I realized what the show was about
I was like all right it's two weeks I'm
going to go to Europe for a month it's
first time I'm traveling out of the
country I could use the money why not so
I go in there and on the very first day
Jen yuger comes in he's like rushing in
he's super late he's got a bunch of
papers in his hands I'm like Oh my God
look at this this guy so so
unprofessional what am I doing here I'm
glad it's only going to be two weeks but
then he sits down and he just starts
railing against the Bush Administration
and their preemptive war in Iraq and
remember this is at a time when the news
wasn't really telling the truth about
what how much of a disaster that war was
how much of a disaster our war crimes
were we were committing war crimes you
know the Bush Administration was and it
just felt so refreshing to see someone
give the audience the facts about what
was happening on the ground but also
just tell the truth about how much this
is going to lead to backlash toward the
United States how counterproductive this
is and I just really appreciated that so
once I saw how he conducted himself and
how he was telling the audience what the
reality was I didn't want to leave and
eventually um things kind of came to a
head because
the company was in Dire Straits
financially speaking uh we were carried
on something called air America radio
that's where the majority of the revenue
was coming from at that time and so air
America had gone bankrupt at this time
I'm working both jobs I'm still at CBS
because that's the stable job I love tyt
but it's not so stable and it might go
under any minute because of air America
going bankrupt and Jen calls me into his
office I'll never forget this day I
remember it so vividly he just tells me
listen I need you to quit CBS and I was
like o okay but looks like tyt is in
trouble you guys might go under like
what happens if I quit my stable job
work at tyt and you guys go bankrupt and
he's like well that's life in the big
city and apparently that one line was
persuasive enough for me to quit my job
at CVS sold yeah and it was the best
decision I made I mean it was a risk at
the time I guess if you want to think of
it that way but I realized that I was so
so unhappy with what my future would
have been if I stayed at CBS that I just
decided to take that risk and figure it
out from there and look what you guys
have done now okay the two of you guys
it's amazing great story thank you for
sharing your story I think it's the best
transition into the story that came out
yesterday Americans Trust in Media
plummets to Historic low okay so this is
an axio story Americans Trust in Media
has fallen to Historic low according to
new polling from Gallup trust and media
has previously dropped to 32% in 2016
before rebounding slightly those gains
have essentially been wiped out
according to the poll only 32% of
population reports having a great deal
or fair amount of confidence that the
media reports the news in full fair and
accurate way the other uh the only other
time in recent history that trust had
fallen to 32% was in 2016 in some cases
the sentiment is worse today record high
numbers number of Americans 39% said
they don't trust the media at all that
number has steadily increased since 2018
much of the sentiment dip is driven by
democrats and independents whose
Collective Trust in Media has plummeted
18 and 13 percentage points respectively
from their 2018 Peaks why do you think
that is well I think that the
polarization that we're experiencing
with the American electorate is
reflected in how the media conducts
itself I think depending on what you're
watching you will get only half of the
story um and then so I think that's
definitely true of some of the more New
Media Outlet independent Outlets they
cater to a very specific portion of the
audience very specific portion of the
electorate and I think Americans are
increasingly realizing okay I might be
in a ideological bubble depending on
what kind of news I'm consuming so you
have that then on a more corporate level
if you want to put it that way uh
corporate media Legacy
Media I mean they've gotten so many
things wrong over the years and I think
that all of those mistakes add up in
people's minds and it leads to distrust
so I look I'll give you an example that
I think you guys are probably definitely
going to agree with um but then I'll
also talk about it in the context of
some of the stories that I got wrong
because I relied on Legacy Media so in
the leadup to the Muller report if you
were consuming the New York Times NBC if
Legacy Media was what you relied on for
your information
you were under the impression that
without question the Muller report will
prove that Donald Trump had colluded
there was a big conspiracy between
Donald Trump Vladimir Putin and
Russia the report did not bear that out
and it was
just I just felt like I was misled by a
lot of that reporting I felt like a
sucker for buying that reporting so that
already was like a major hit when it
came to my trust in corporate media
Legacy Media then I saw the way they
treated uh Jen yuger when he ran for
congress the lies they told about him
were outrageous and I was like oh my God
I don't know what to believe from them
if they are willing to literally take an
interview he did with David Duke that
was a super heated interview Jen was not
friendly to him I mean they took a
sarcastic comment that Jen made in the
context of that interview and they
reported it as if he was like he wasn't
sarcastic like he meant what he said and
you go back and you watch that interview
you watch that statement and you're like
no it's very obvious he's being
sarcastic here so you start losing trust
as these I don't even want to say
mistakes I feel like in some cases some
reporters have an agenda and their
agenda becomes clear in their
misreporting intentional intentional now
I don't think that's always the case I
don't think that's the case the majority
of the time but when I look at the
stories that I got wrong during the coid
era right and mostly culture War related
stories it's because the media
intentionally and I'm going to say
intentionally omitted incredibly
important details of those various
controversial Stories the Kyle
writtenhouse story perfect example of
that I got that story wrong because I
relied on corporate media and look I I
have to hold myself accountable so I'm
not saying that to place blame or
transfer the blame onto others I should
have done my due diligence and I should
have gone out of my way to read from
reporters that might have a different
perspective I didn't do that and now
I've learned to really go out of my way
to understand the arguments made on all
sides but if you are relying on one new
source or if you are under the
impression that the media Outlets that
have been around forever are the most
credible the most legitimate and the
most accurate you will be misled you
really do have to have a healthy diverse
media diet in order to get a better
grasp on what's Happening in the country
and in the world and and you made a
great point and you mentioned it was
like right with the Trump and all that
can you bring that chart back up Rob
notice how in 2016 Donald Trump the
election where's that you you have that
look look at at 2016 Rob look at look at
that drop that Republicans are like we
know that they're lying but look at how
Democrat you're showing this so the
audience knows the redest Republicans
blue is Democrat Democrat the dot is so
Independence kind of pack gradually went
down Anna but notice the the Republicans
knew that they were full of crap but
isn't that crazy Democrats were like oh
my God we love the the they're telling
the truth about Trump and everything but
then look at it's still slowly gradually
dropping down to 58% but it's crazy how
that moment in time at the 2016 that
election the Trump and everything it was
like the right when he said fake news
people were like yeah whatever he's full
of crap but look at that who's dat is
this whose report is this who's the
source I don't know but it's but like an
independent survey I know Gallup just
put out surve because Pat my
understanding is if you take out sports
scores in weather this is actually
zero for Democrats no media Trust in
Media if you take out sports scores and
weather it's actually zero oh I see what
you're saying got it so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here